FINALLY
LOTS-OF-SHOWS GIVE AWAY CARS BUT
HAS A HOST EVER GIVEN AWAY THEIR
OWN PERSONAL CAR?
I HAVE NO IDEA.
I'M NOT SAYING I'M BETTER THAN
OPRAH EVEN THOUGH PEOPLE WHO
KNOW HER SAID THAT.
I AM GIVING AWAY MY OWN 2011
SUBARU OUTBACK TO ONE LUCKY FAN.
GO AHEAD, LOSE YOUR MIND.
KNOW I ONLY HAVE ONE CAR, NOT
MULTIPLE CARS.
SO ALL MY LIFE'S ADVENTURES IN
THE LAST THREE YEARS HAVE TAKEN
PLACE IN THIS BABY.
SHE'S FULLY LOADED.
THE FAKE MANUAL MODE.
THE WINDOWS ARE TINTED.
THAT'S NOT LEGAL.
ROLL 'EM DOWN IF YOU SEE A COP.
HAVE I GOTTEN TO THIRD BASE IN
THAT CAR?
BETTER BELIEVE IT.
THEN I STOPPED.
I DON'T GO PAST THIRD BASE.
I'M NOT JUST GOING TO GIVE IT
AWAY.
YOU WANT A BRAND-NEW SECONDHAND
WHIP, YOU BETTER WORK, BITCH.
I NEED TO KNOW YOUR SOMEONE
REMARKABLE.
SEND ME A VIDEO PROVING YOUR
BETTER THAN ME.
FILM YOURSELF DOING SOMETHING.
CHALLENGE ME.
IMPRESS ME.
OR JUST BEG FOR MY CAR.